الان الى الهواجس البيئيه التي يعيش
العالم على وقعها فقد اكدت الامم المتحده
ان الاعوام الماضيه كانت الاكثر حراره على
الاطلاق وذلك بسبب ارتفاع متواصل في تركز
غازات الغازات الدفينه وتراكم الحرب
من 16 معدا في جميع انحاء العالم خلصت الى
ان محيطات العالم سجلت بدورها مستويات
حراره قياسيه للعام الرابع على التوالي في
عام 2022
بالامر المقلق
المحيطات تغطي واحدا وسبعين في المئه من
سطح الارض هذه المساحات البارده الهائله
تمتص اكثر من 90 في المئه من الحراره التي
تحبسها انبعاثاتنا من غازات الاحتباس
الحراري واساسا ثاني اكسيد الكربون قد
سجلت المحيطات حراره قياسيه جديده للعام
الماضي حسب ما ذكرت دراسه نشرها الاربعاء
فريق دولي من العلماء
وخلص موعد الدراسه التي نشرت نتائجها مجله
ادفنسز
الى ان المحيطات تستمر في الاحترار على
مستوى العالمي وترتفع درجه حرارتها الان 8
مرات اسرع مما كانت عليه في السنوات ال 25
الماضيه
تخبرنا اتجاهاته درجات الحراره في
المحيطات قصه مدمره للغايه
منذ عقود ونرى تداعيتها الان اذا نظرنا
الى درجات الحراره من سنه الى اخرى او من
عقد الى عقد فهي ترتفع باستمرار وبلا
هواده وهنا سبب اهميه ذلك
المحيطات وهي محركات
مناخيرها يغير انماط الطقس على مستوى
العالم
وهذا سبب حدوثي موجات حر كارثه
وفيضانات القويه وكلما زادت حراره الماء
زاد محتوى الرطوبه بشكل كبير
الى كميات القياسيه من الامطار
فيضانات في باكستان ونيجيريا وتشاد وغيرها
علاوه على ذلك فان التسخيله داخل المحيطات
نفسها
قنبله بيئيه موقوته من قتل وتبييض الشعب
المرجانيه والاحياء البحريه المياه
الساخنه تعني ايضا المياه الموسوعه مما
يعني ارتفاع مستوى سطح البحر نحن في
طريقنا لارتفاع مستوى سطح البحر بمقدار
متر واحدا بحلول مطلع القرن
ايوه هدد حياه عشرات الملايين من البشر
المزيد تنضم الينا من فيينا ديالا الحسيني
الباحثه المختصه في شؤون البيئه والمناخ
سيد الحسيني هل من مؤشرات بان خطوات عمليه
ستتخذ للحد من هذه الكارثه الصح التعبير
الامم المتحده لتنوع البيولوجيا مباشره
مباشره
اندونيسيا في منطقه جاوا مبادرات في
امريكا كلها بقت تصب في الاستثمار في
التوسع المحافظه على اشجار المانجرو
والشعب المرجانيه لتفادي الاحترار الاكثر
في البحار والمحيطات ومن المعلوم انها كل
ما ارتفع درجه حراره المحيطات كلما تفاقمت
ايضا انظمه المناخ كما ذكرت تقريبا
العواصف
الفيضانات هناك ايضا احتمال رمضان
لكن هذه الخطوات والمبادرات التي تحدثت
عنها هل هي كافيه ام ان هناك المزيد على
الدول بالتحديد عليها القيام به لتفادي
كوارث اكبر همم يواجهها كوكب الارض
نعم اذا ما تحدثنا اليوم البحار والمحيطات
فهي الحاجز الامن للكره الارضيه فاليوم
يجب ان يكون برامج دوليه كبيره ومشتركه هو
الحل الاكثر
استدراك يعني اتجهنا نحو الكربون الازرق
على الدول الكبرى او العظمى
ان توفى الدول الناميه
البيئيه
القادمه فهذا التمويل لغايه اليوم همم
حول الارقام التمويل
فتحنا نتحدث اليوم مبادرات او برامج
ان يرتفع مستوى سطح البحر تقريبا
او يقضي على عدد كبير جدا من المناطق
المدن الساحليه او المناطق المنخفضه
فبالتالي يجب ان يكون هناك ايضا لي
فبركاته خاصه في مؤتمر جماعه المناخ
القادمه ان شاء الله ممكن ان يكون هناك في
حلول وخاصه في موضوع التمويل لتستطيع كما
ذكرنا الدول من التكيف واطلاق البرامج
الكافيه لهذا الغرب
استفيد من جودك معنا لاسال همم السؤال
التالي دون ادنى شك بان المنظمات والحركات
التي تعنى بالبيئه لاعب الدوره اساسيا
بالتوعيه همم حتى يومنا هذا ولكن بعض
المجموعات اصبحت تاخذ منحه غير سلمي اذا
صحت تعبير نشاهد عمليات تخريب لوحات همم
او همم لبعض الوجهات كيف تصفون هذه
الممارسه هل تخدم القضيه الام بتقديريك
لا طبعا لا تخدمه هي ممارسات للفت النظر
كون ان القضايا البيئيه بنظرهم قضايا
اهميه ذات اهميه اكبر للالتفات اليها من
القضايا الاخرى لانها لا تهدف الغرض
بالتاكيد يعني كل الامور التي تدعي الى
التخريب او الارهاب البيئي للفتره الاخيره
لا يخدم هذا الغرض
زواج
اعلامي الكبير
الا ان القطط الدوليه
الدولي مع المؤسسات الصغيره والحكوميه هي
التي من الممكن ان تؤدي الى الشعريه
ملموسه غير هذا لا يمكن الا لف نظر لا
اكثر ولا اقل وقد يرد من يؤيد هذه همم
التحركات من قبل الناشطين بان الدول كذلك
اجرمت في حق البيئه وهي بحاجه الى ربما
تحركات صادمه لتتخذ خطوات التؤيدين هذا
الكلام
طبعا نحن نؤيد ان الدول العظمى او الدول
الصناعيه الكبرى هي المتسببه الاكبر
بالاحتباس الحراري والغازات التي تسبب
التماره اليوم الا ان انا
نحكي انه الحوار او المفاوضات على على
طاولات النقاش ممكن ان تؤدي ايضا الى
الضغط على الدول الناميه او الدول
الصناعيه الكبرى التامويل التامين الدعم
الكافرين خطط المستقبليه
للمبادلات التكيف او حتى مواجهه هذه
الامور لان الامور التخريبيه للوحه النظر
للقضايا البيئيه يمكن ان تكون ممكن ان
تكون او ان تؤدي الى فعليا تتصل الرساله
الا انها بشكل عام منبوذه من الجهاز
الصخره اليوم في اتجاه نحو العصيان المدني
في المناجم المناجم او حتى الادراك في
الشركات الكبرى المتسببه او التي تسبب
الانتهاكات حق الحيوانات او حق البيئه
هناك احتجاجات سلميه ممكن ان تصل هذه
الرساله شكرا
لك يا سيدي الحسين الباحث المختصه في شؤون
البيئه